o pessoal aqui quem fala é dar que sejam
muito bem vindos a mais um vídeo e um
estrago de que o novo brinquedo vejam só
e esse brinquedo chamas urubus pronto
basicamente é um tubo de escape para
bicicleta acho que ele fica até mais
rápido eu não sei mas eu comprei por
isso mesmo pessoal porque eu vi essa
imagem eu pensei em tubo de escape para
bicicleta como assim cm e 50 não tem
motor mas vai ser uma derrota que vai
ficar o episódio racista mas deve ser
mentira max o pai com um look em salt
lake um novo turbo aip e agora tem que
seguir isso faz com que a bicicleta faz
um barulho de moto mesmo ser que ainda
tem 20 dize espetacular
em 2012 vamos lá ver se tem mesmo e em
321 ou é muito bacana plástico
fui enganado já comprei um brinquedo
falso
o cientista foi enganado não pode ser eu
vou fazer isso funcionar daqui tem hoje
vejam só aqui tem exausto eu acho que
estou por aqui o principal é que tem
três motor cars cartas mota eu acho que
não vale o dobro de moquecas vários
barulhos deve ser um cartão por um
barulho mais alto outro mais baixo outro
sim mas deus sabe se o canadá e outro de
ser tanta gente não tá nem aí o que você
deve ser assim
[Música]
é uma moda triste mas valeu a pena o
nosso brinquedo só falei então aqui tem
uns 20 exibido em fuga o motorista sul
foi aí que o 2
eu acho que tudo isso de forma errada
não pergunta e que pessoal tem o
principal o nosso tubo de escape
episódio mas o pai piso estava e que não
tem mais instruções foca o teu motocard
e pedala o máximo que conseguir seis
assadas quem a com mais força possível
conseguir o terceiro maior bike lora que
faz oito bicicletas e fugiram para abrir
o nosso brinquedo em forma mas antes eu
quero pedir uma grande grande ajuda eu
quero que vocês deixem muito aqui neste
vídeo porque só assim este vídeo vai se
espalhar pelo mundo e os organismos
todos os planetas e galáxias vão saber
que esse filho existe então deixa eu vou
falar isso por escrito aqui no canal
pessoal inscrevam os portenhos
iluministas também conceber que isso
existe e eu quero eu quero com julinho
mas faz-me vídeos sempre quis ter uma
coisa destas tanto que eu não comprava
este brinquedo mas que usava latas de
coca cola na bicicleta
eu acho que algumas pessoas só que
estraga o pneu né então isso aqui com
certeza que não estraga o pneu
olha só olha só nos tubos capô que tem
mesmo coisas dentro tem ferro já
financiou um todo mesmo eu acho que
mostrei nada era necessário pois não
vamos tentar fazer com isso falta 51
presos pessoal que nós temos e que
permitirá que no futuro de capo eu acho
que é só o pessoal colocar assim
empolada roda esta parte aqui eu não sei
por que eu vou tentar adivinhar quando
eu tenho um manual de instruções que não
está aqui eu acho que é a mesma dentro
da cabeça
acho que o melhor é não explicam como um
texto
aí eu era como um só ataque dentro desse
papel plástico vai faltar essa profusão
só que temos de instruções lei muitas
coisas que fazemos só tem muito espaço e
8º fácil andar então tem certo ficou a
lei em três cartões
isso é o que a horizon é isso o que eu
disse olha que este é o valor mais
pequeno porque tem menos questões e isto
aqui é um centro médico que só tem dois
e esse é o que faz muito barulho a lei
porque é tudo cartão tem 500 de 256 é
isso mesmo se três notas apae
acho que é assim ou é simples mas eu não
vou conseguir montar isso então vamos
colocar já na sua bicicleta e ver o que
acontece é que minha bicicleta atrás
[Música]
olha eu vou destruir o brinquedo é que
nós vamos colocar assim é muito mais
fácil eu acho que vai ficar com uma
coisa assim precisa nem
vamos ver o papel e torcedores mesmo em
olha esse índice é tacho ruiz um canto
finalmente consegui colocar aqui em
nossa peça ela está precisamente aqui
que funciona mas ainda não silva que o
plano de mota que eu quero então vamos
lá colocar o cartão pode kalil é
jornalista aqui e é mais potente e seu
outro kart 500 só que eu acho que é só
enfiar assim e eu combati que no raio de
bicicleta vai fazer um barulho então
vamos ouvir 32 o vai voltar com muita
força para 31 uma moda mas faltou
prender o cartão porque eu senti que eu
saio daqui quando lá se o primeiro aqui
fillon
acho que é isso que temos um problema no
entanto surge acho que já tinha a cara
com os problemas nunca ninguém é assim
eu sofrem com sofrem mas ainda falta
alguma coisa muito importante só que o
nosso tubo de escape esse item que está
a organismo está aqui o que faz um
barulho mas que isso é importante ter
prática o espírito visual na sua
bicicleta prova e agora é que eu
coloquei e nós não temos a pensar o
contrário porque ficar aqui até então
vamos fazer isso tudo eu espero não
curtir 321 vai talvez não acho que esse
é sim uma cueca e agora só vamos colocar
em nosso tubo de café e achucarro agora
está tudo muito bem empresa quando és o
meu tá muito ruim do jovem jonas e mata
sul e agora é a segunda parte que mais
gosto que é claro os 900 isso porque a
primeira parte vai ser um dar não sou
boquinha
[Música]
eu tentei
só vejam só tem 15 dos parafusos mil
acerto está muito muito louca aí um
parafuso outro preços lei sobre quem
está em 2 para fugir da queda e isso não
tem com quem clinton para nós não só
nosso tubo de escape está pronto a nossa
bicicleta também está pronto e agora é
só estará na área de forma calma com
muita carro com muita calma funciona
porque só vou lá por fora na hora
[Música]
i won
só vamos lá tira a tampa 321 vai mesmo
tentar adaptar seu prejuízo do inteiro e
em 321 vai aqui eu disse só que este
funcionário cientista faz tudo cinara
olha aí o perdão outro cartão já não
temos mais o meu pessoal para
experimentar a moto é mais fraca
[Música]
raj não entra só vocês já viram um banho
barulho da outra moto vamos lá ver como
é que isso funciona
eu gosto mais sério
a ajuda já estou cansado mas falta um
cartão fato experimentar um cartão e o
eu acho que isso é um pouco mais rápido
[Aplausos]
mas com outro aparelho assim meu deus eu
pensei vamos pra casa andar mais
ufa distingue segunda ronda com que o
rio grande por bill não é que estudos já
funciona mesmo não era eu acho que o
punk bicicletada a 100 ocorrendo a
corrente da bicicleta os lá dentro que é
melhor conta já que só acabou por
segurar profuso olha só 1 234 então eu
produzo e só fica preso - acho que conta
grosso grupo está disposto a encaixar o
índice é e não é só o aspecto de um
estado que decidir já sabe quanto com
muito líquido da nossa parte aqui neste
vídeo componente 123 vezes o contágio a
4 sim muito light estão foi escrito aqui
no canal só inscrevam senão vocês vão
bater um tiro de meta
nesta segunda o xampu no local vazou
só fique meta
[Música]